بالنسبه لبومبيو فان قطر تقوم بدور مهم
لخفض التوتر في افغانستان وتدعم الاستقرار
في غزه ولبنان وسوريا رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه قال ايضا ان الاوان قد ان
لانهاء الازمه الخليجيه وان اداره ترامب
حريصه على حل هذا النزاع واعاده فتح حدود
قطر الجويه والبريه المغلقه اما نائب رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الرحمن ال ثاني فقال ان موقف بلاده
بشان الازمه الخليجيه ثابت في الانفتاح
على الحوار من دون شروط جاء هذه التصريحات
خلال الجلسه السنويه الثالثه للحوار
الاستراتيجي بين الولايات المتحده وقطر
المنعقده هذا العام في واشنطن فاي افاق
للعلاقات الخارجيه الخليجيه وما دلالات
الاشاده الامريكيه بموقف قطر وادوارها
المتعدده لم يثني قطر الحصار الذي فرض
عليها قبل ثلاث سنوات عن القيام بادوار
دبلوماسيه على مستوى المنطقه والعالم يت م
ذلك من خلال انطلاق الجوله الثالثه من
الحوار الاستراتيجي بين الولايات المتحده
وقطر حيث اشاد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
مايك بومبيو بدور الدوحه في تحقيق الامن
والاستقرار في قضايا استراتيجيه واقليميه
كبرى ورهان واشنطن على دور الدوحه من
افغانستان حتى غزه مرورا بلبنان
وسوريا تلعب قطر دورا لا يقدر بثمن في
المساعده على استقرار غزه وكذلك في الجهود
الاقليميه لتهدئه التوترات في كل من سوريا
ولبنان كما لم ينسى بومبيو التذكير بضروره
حل الخلاف الخليجي وانهاء الانقسام وفتح
الحدود لاغلاق الباب امام التدخل الايراني
المتزايد حان الوقت لايجاد حل للصراع
الخليجي ان اداره ترامب حريصه على حل هذا
النزاع واعاده فتح حدود قطر الجويه
والبريه المقفله من دول الخليج الاخرى
نتطلع الى احراز تقدم في هذا الشان الخلاف
الخليجي وحصار قطر مثلا تح شدد نائب رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الرحمن الثاني على ان بلاده تجاوزت
بل باتت اكثر قوه بعد ان طورت علاقات غير
مسبوقه مع الاسره
الدوليه رغم التحديات الاقليميه التي
نواجه بما فيها الحصار المستمر على بلدنا
فشراء المتحده منذ احتضان قطر للجوله
الاولى للحوار الاستراتيجي لبلدينا في
ناير
2018 اود ان اشكر واشنطن على دعمها
للوساطه الكويتيه لانهاء الحصار على اساس
احترام سياده واستقلال دوله قطر والسياسه
الخارجيه القطريه مستمره في تحقيق
الازدهار والسلم والاستقرار وهي عناصر
تعكس قيمنا التي بفضلها تقف قطر اقوى من
ذي قبل في وجه الحصار بعد ان طورت
علاقاتها بالاسره الدوليه الى مستوى غير
مسبوق طريقه تعامل قطر مع الحصار كانت محل
اشاده المسؤولين الامريكيين الذين يراهنون
على دورها وقوتها الناعمه في اكثر من ملف
خصوصا في افغانستان مع سعي اداره الرئيس
دونالد ترامب لانهاء اطول الحروب
الامريكيه وهم يرون ان انهاء الحصار
واستعاده الوحده في الخليج بات امرا حتميا
من اجل التركيز على القضايا الاستراتيجيه
والاقليميه الملحه وعدم تشتيت التركيز على
خلاف ثبت للقاصي والداني ان انه مصطنع
وعبثي اناقش الموضوع مع ضيوفنا هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور ماجد الانصاري استاذ علم
الاجتماع السياسي في جامعه قطر من واشنطن
الباحث المتخصص في شؤون الشرق الاوسط
سيجورد نيو باور ومن عمان الدكتور حسن
البراري استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
الجامعه الاردنيه اهلا بكم جميعا دكتور
ماجد ما دلالات هذا الاصرار والزخم
الامريكي والاسراع في حل الازمه الخليجيه
طبعا جلال يعني هذه ليست اول مره يتحدث
فيها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الحالي
والسابق عن ضروره حل هذه الازمه باسرع وقت
ممكن ربما يكون المختلف في هذه المره
تحديدا هو في نقطتين رئيسيتين الاولى هو
الاشاده المتكرره بجهود قطر ودورها في
المنطقه ونجاحها في تجاوز الحصار يعني هو
يتحدث عن هذا الامر باعجاب وبث اناء باسم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا ربما يكون
امر متجدد الامر الثاني هو التركيز هذه
المره على فكره المعابر الجويه والمعابر
البريه وهذه ربما اضافه احنا سمعنا في
الفتره الماضيه الكلام عن المعابر الجويه
اليوم هناك كلام عن المعابر البريه
ويتزامن تمون هذه النقطه تحديدا يعني انا
اعتقد انه ربما يكون هناك الان وضوح في
الملفات التي تريد واشنطن الاسراع بحلها
وتجاوز هذا الملف الاجواء وعلاقه الولايات
المتحده بفكره ان تطير الطائرات القطريه
فوق الاجواء الايرانيه تجاوز هذا الى
مرحله ضروره يعني فك العقده الاجتماعيه في
هذه الازمه من خلال فتح المعابر بشكل كامل
الامر الاخر هو ان نتحدث هنا الان يعني في
ظل ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اليوم هي في يعني في زخم توقيع
اتفاقيات السلام سيتم بعد يومين وكذا
ولكنها كانت حريصه على اقامه هذا الحوار
وجدولت هذا الحوار قبل ذلك
وا اسباغ هذا الموقف على قطر قبل الانخراط
في هذا الامر وربما سنتحدث بعد قليل عن
حتى الامور الاخرى المرتبطه بغزه وسوريا
وغيرها ملفات المنطقه اسمع رئيس سيد نوبور
سيد نوبور اذا بومبيو قال بانه ان الاوان
لط هذه الصفحه وحل الخلاف الخليجي كما قال
الدكتور ماجد هو مطلب امريكي منذ وقت بعيد
ولكن هل تعتقد انه اصبحوا اصبح هدفا ملحا
في هذه المرحله للاداره
الامريكيه نعم بالتاكيد
علينا ان نفكر ببعض الحقائق ف بومبيو
وجيرت كوشنر كان في المنطقه في الاسبوع
الماضي والاسبوع الذي قبله وان بومبي اكد
على نفس الموضوع مع محمد بن زايد في ابو
ظبي وكذلك جورد كوشنر وبالتالي فانه كان
عنما كان جورد كوشنر في الدحا ايضا قال
ذلك واعتقد المهم ان نفهم انه في حين ان
هناك هذا الحوار استراتيجي مع الولايات
المتحده مع قطر الا ان علينا ان ننسى ان
الشيخ عبد محمد رحمن وزير خارجيه قطر هو
كان في هو حاليا في في واشنطن في وقت وجود
عبد الله بن زايد اليان في واشنطن ونحن
نعلم ان وزير خارجيه الامارات وصل يوم
مساء الاحد هنا الى واشنطن ونعلم بان
الامارات ستقوم مراسم توقيع معاده السلام
غدا وبالتالي لماذا نجد ان القطر وزير
خارجيه قطر والامارات في واشنطن في الوقت
ذاته نحن طبعا لا نعرف بالضبط ما يحصل
وراء الكواليس ولكن التوقيق لا يمكن ان
يكون مصادفه من الواضح جدا ان الاداره
الامريكيه
بدات تضع ضغوطا كبيره جدا على الامارات
لرفع هذا الحصار وتطبيع علاقاتها مع قطر
وبالتالي هذه هي الامور التي تجري خلف
الكواليس واعتقد ان هذا في غايه
الامين ان ان هذا الحوار الاستراتيجي بين
قطر والولايات المتحده يحصل حاليا وبالضبط
قبل قيام التوقيع على اتفاقيه الامارات
واسرائيل غدا سريعا دكتور وهو يعني يشير
سيد نيو باور الى الى شيء ما ولكن هذا هذا
الحوار استراتيجي هو مجدول مجدول مسبقا
صحيح نعم نعم وحقيقه انا الان يعني استبعد
ان تكون هذه فرصه ل مثل ما يفترض سيجورد
الزميل سيجورد ان يكون هناك فعلا يعني
فرصه لقاء بين الطرفين في هذا ال طيب
دكتور حسن موقف الدوحه واضح من اليوم
الاول الحوار وطاوله الحوار هي الحل
الوحيد لتخطي هذه الازمه بينما كانت الدول
المحاصره لقطر ترفض الحصار ومصره على
الشروط ب قيمك ما المقاربه التي تغيرت
الان او كيف اصبحت مقاربه هذه الدول لحل
الازمه
الخليجيه الدول لم تتغير الذي تغير هو ان
السرديه القطريه انتصرت وبالتالي الملفت
في حديث وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ محمد
بن عبد الرحمن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بومبيو هو ان دوله قطر هي مصره على موقفها
بانها لم تدعم الارهاب وانها هي عنصر
استقرار في هذه المنطقه وهذه الاشاده جاءت
على لسان بومبيو بعد ان ت ماسس الحوار الا
الاستراتيجي بين قطر بين دوله قطر وبين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فبالتالي هذا
بدوره يبعث برساله واضحه الى كل الدول
التي حاولت شيطنه قطر والتي بدلت يعني
كانت سخيه في بدل كثير ربما عشرات ان لم
يكن مئات الملايين من الدولارات على مكاتب
العلاقات العامه لوسم قطر بانها تدعم
وترعى الارهاب هذا كله كان صرحا من خيال
فهوه انتهى هذا لم يعد في المجتمع الدولي
من يصدق هذا الكلام
بعد ان ثبت ان قطر هي قوتها الناعمه
والخشنه هي هي كونستركت بمعنى بناءه وهي
ليست سلبيه كما هو في حال خصومه الذين
يحتلون اليمن الذين قسموا اليمن الذين
يعبثون بشرق المتوسط الذين ايضا في ليبيا
يعبثون في هذه في هذا الملف فبالتالي
المقارنه امام المجتمع الدولي ان قطر تمثل
عنصر استقرار وعنصر بناء وقوه بناءه في
حين ان خصومها سقطت سرديته ولم يقتنع
تقتنع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
الاقل بانه قطر هي دوله تمول او ترعى
الارهاب فبالتالي انا بتقدير ان السرديه
القطريه انتصرت واصبحت واضحه للجميع في
المجتمع الدولي فبالتالي الكره الان في
ملعب الدول الخليجيه الاخرى التي اخفقت
اخفاق كبيرا في تثبيت مقولاتها ضد قطر طيب
الان هو السؤال الاساسي يعني هل يمكن
لدوله مثل الامارات ان تطبع مع اسرائيل
التي تحتل الاراضي الفلسطينيه والتي تهاجر
الفلسطينيين وهي مسؤوله عن نكبتهم
التاريخيه وهي ما زالت تحتل يعني احتلال
استيطاني احلالي مووجود في الضفه الغربيه
ولا تطبع مع دوله قطر التي التي لا تهدد
الامارات ولا تهدد السعوديه وهي كانت
الطرف المتلقي وبخاصه بعد ان ثبتت ان ان
ان لقطر سياسه حكيمه في السياسه في
الملفات الخارجيه وفي التعامل مع الازمه
وفي اداره ازمه كان مثار اعجاب يعني كل ما
صدر عن عن مايك بومبيو هو اشاده بدور قطر
الولايات المتحده لا تحتاج الى قطر لا
تتقرب من قطر وتجامل هي تدرك اهميه قطر
موقعها الجيوسياسي حقيقه ان هناك تحالف
استراتيجي وعسكري ايضا متمثل بوجود قاعده
العديد فبالتالي هذا يضيف من قوه قطر وقوه
ردع قطر ايضا امام خصومه فبالتالي لا يوجد
اي قوه في العالم يمكن ان تتحرش عسكريا
بقطر كما فكرت دول الحصار في البدايه طبعا
هذا ما فهمناه باثر رجعي باختصار شديد
الرساله واضحه تماما بانه لا يمكن لهذا
الحصار ان يستمر فقد كل مبرراته و وتهاوت
يعني فبالتالي الكره كما قلت انا في
البدايه في مرمى الرياض في مرمى ايضا ابو
ظبي والبحرين وايضا القاهره ا لا يعقل ان
يستمر هذا الحصار الظالم على قطر وبخاصه
بعد ان فشل فشلا ذريعا وبقيت قطر مصره على
موقفها بانها عنصر استقرار بانها قوه
بناءه وبانها لا تمو الارهاب بل هي تحارب
الارهاب بدليل بدليل انها جزء من التحالف
الدولي لمناهضه داعش دكتور
الانصاري ما حظوظ نجاح اداره الرئيس
الامريكي الان في طي هذا الملف لانه يعني
كانت هناك محاولات امريكيه سابقه انت ذكرت
من ضمن المبادره او الوساطه الكويتيه
ولكنها لم تنجح حتى اخر محاوله في اخر
العام الماضي قيل في تقارير امريكيه بان
الامارات اجهدتها في مراحلها المتقدمه ما
الاوراق التي تمتلكها الاداره الامريكيه
الان لانجاح هذا المساع يعني هو الان هناك
نمط متك في محاولات الولايات المتحده
لتحقيق اي تقدم في ملف الازمه الخليجيه
يبدو ان دول الحصار اصبحت اليوم تتعامل
بناء على النمط التالي هي تبدا في البدايه
بقبول هذا الضغط والتعامل معه بوعود
وبعطيها ثم تخترق اليه معينه لافشال هذه
الجهود واضعاف هذه المساله واللعب على قصر
الاتنشن سبان قصر خط الاهتمام الذي هو لدى
الاداره الامريكيه بان شغالها بامور اخرى
ونعتقد اليوم ونحن لا تفصلنا الا يعني اقل
من شهرين على الانتخابات امريكيه فان هذه
الدول تعلم انها ليست بحاجه لان تقدم
تنازلات كبيره لصالح الاداره الامريكيه
ليس امام ترامب اليوم الا ان يلعب على عكس
ما تم من قبل الامارات في الاتفاق مع
اسرائيل اتفاق السلام مع اسرائيل ارادت هي
من خلال هذا الاتفاق حصول على مكاسب
اللحظه الاخيره من ترامب في اجندتها في
المنطقه وبامكان الاداره الامريكيه ان
تقول ان هذه المكاسب هي مرهونه ايضا بان
تحققوا تقدما بالنسبه لملف الازمه
الخليجيه فبالتالي اذا اردتم ان تستثمروا
اتفاق مع اسرائيل عليكم كذلك ان تقدموا
تنازلا في هذا الملف ولكن للامانه نحن
نعلم ان حتى الان الاداره ليس لديها يعني
قدره عاليه على توظيف ادوات الضغط التي
لدى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
التعامل مع السعوديه والامارات بشكل اساسي
المساله الاخرى هنا ان الولايات المتحده
في كل المرات التي دفعت بها في الوساطه
كان طبعا داعمه للوساطه الكويتيه اولا
والامر الثان انها كانت تعتمد على وجود
صاحب السمو الشيخ صباح الاحمد امير الكويت
اعاده الله سالما معافا الى بلده وهو الان
يغيب طبعا في هذه اللحظه التاريخيه بحكم
مرض انس الله له الشفاء ولكن اليوم
اللاعبون صحيح انهم موجودون بشكل او باخر
ولكن هناك غياب للوساطه الكويتيه بشكل
اساسي وهناك ايضا حاله تصعيد اعلامي كبيره
جدا في اعلام الامارات والاعلام السعودي
المدعوم اماراتيا فيما يبدو في محاوله
لاستباق اي ضغط امريكي حقيقي لذلك الظروف
غير مهيئه ولكن للامانه في ظل يعني
التقلبات اليوميه للمواقف التي نراها لا
نستغرب ان نجد ضغط حقيقي امريكي في
اللحظات الاخيره في الساعه الاخيره من يوم
ترامب الاول في البيت الابيض حتى يحدث
تغييرا على الارض تقصد في في ولايته
الثانيه في في في اليوم الاخير اقصد فيلاه
الاولى يوم الاخير طبعا السؤال هنا لماذا
تريد واشنطن او يعني ماذا ستستفيد بواشنطن
نحن نعلم كنا دائما نقول في لقاءات مختلفه
ان السياسه التي ينتهجها ترامب هي سياسه
تعاقديه ف بالتالي هو يبحث الان عن كويت
بوكو ما هو البديل الذي سيحصل عليه مقابل
ان ان ينجح في هذه الوساطه هو كان يريد
مشاهد انتصار في السياسه الخارجيه تحقق له
ان يعني يغلق بعض الملفات التي وعد بها
خلال حمله الانتخابيه في 2016 اليوم هو
لديه الصور بين بومبيو وقاده طالبان
لديه الانجاز بالنسبه لاتفاق الامارات
والبحرين مع اسرائيل لديه ملفات خارجيه
ناجحه هو ليس بحاجه كبيره لهذا الملف لانه
لا يخدمه داخليا بشكل كبير جدا مثل
الملفات الاخرى ولا يعتبر واحد من وعوده
التي قدمها في 2016 ويكفيه ان يقول انه
قادر على ان يستثمر شركاء في المنطقه من
خلال هذه الملفات لذلك المكسب الاعلامي
الانتخابي من وراء مصالحه خليجيه اليوم هو
نسبيا محدود اذا ما استثنينا الجزئيه
المتعلقه بايقاف الطيران الطائرات القطريه
فوق الاجواء الايرانيه حت ولكنه يريد جبهه
لمواجهه ايران وسنتحدث عن هذا لاحقا سيد
نيو باور نقطه طرحها الدكتور الانصاري ما
هي اوراق الضغط التي تملكها الاداره
الامريكيه في هذه المرحله على الدول
المحاصره لقطر لحثها فعليا على انهاء هذا
الحصار اعتقد ان الضغوط فعلا مورست
ونفذت ولكن علينا ان نت كما الحال بالنسبه
الدبلوماسيه الدوليه يكون هناك نتائج
لاحقا و ولكن اعتقد هناك فعلا بدا الشيء
او جهود لمصالحه بين الدول الخليج عندما
عند اما متى سيعلن عن ذلك الاتفاق فلا
نعرف ذلك قد يكون في نهايه السنه بنهايه
الحوار الاستراتيجي مع قطر او قد يكون بعد
اسابيع ولكن ما هو واضح جدا هو ان الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين قط ولايات المتحده لم
تكن ابدا اقوى مما عليه الان وان الا
الامارات
والسعوديه هم هما ب
انفسهما لديهم لديهما ما يدعوهما ان الى
الهاء اللعبه اللاسيه يقومون بها دوليا
شهدنا ذلك كما حصل
في البحرين والامارات باتفاق مع اسرائيل
لكن اود ان اوضح ان كل المجتمع
الدولي يرى ان جميع الولايات المتحده
سعداء جدا بالمساهمات الجيده الايجابيه
تقدمها قطر مثلا في وقف اطلاق النار في
غزه وهذا كان انجازا دبلوماسيا امتدحه
الرئيس الاسرائيلي وكان امرا في غايه
الصعوبه والجاز الدبلماسي الثاني الذي نرى
انه جاري حاليا هو تقليل او تخفيض
القوات الامريكيه في افغانستان مقابل
تصعيد وتشجيع الحوار الافغاني وبالتالي
نجد ان قطر قامت تشارك في عمليتي سلام
مهمتان جده تسعى عليهما الولايات المتحده
و ترغب فيها والولايات المتحده ايضا تضمن
بان دول
الحصار لابد ان يوفوا بالتزاماتهم برفع
الحصار عن قطر هذا سيحصل ولكن لا نعرف متى
سيكون بالضبط لكن على الرجاح سيكون ذلك
قبر الانتخابات الامريكيه بحث ان الرئيس
ترامب يمكن ان يدعي انه حقق انجازا او
نصرا في السياسه الخارجيه جديدا وانا اشعر
بتفاؤل كبير بان سنش
وهو السؤال ايضا كيف دكتور حسن براري في
ظل هذه المتغيرات في المنطقه اخرها طبعا
التطبيع بين اسرائيل ودولتي الامارات
والبحرين هل يمكن تصور كيف يمكن ان يكون
هذا الحل للازمه الخليجيه على اي اسس بحسب
المقاربه
الامريكيه المقاربه الامريكيه واضحه هي
تفيد بان هناك حاجه لايجاد نوع من النيتو
العربي من الجبهه العربيه الموحده لمواجهه
ايران و يعني كان هناك كثير من التصريحات
الامريكيه على جارد كوشنر على الجزيره
تحدث بانه لا يمكن ان تدفع قطر هذه
المبالغ لايران لقاء مرور هذه الطائرات
لان هذا بدوره يمكن ايران فاذا كان هناك
المطالب الخليجيه هي لاضعاف ايران وتقويض
استراتيجيتها في هذه المنطقه لا يمكن ان
ان تقوم بالاستمرار في الحصار قطر وقطر
بدورها لا منفذ لها الا فوق الايران فانا
بتقديري ان يعني حجر الزاويه في كل
المقاربه الامريكيه هو ايجاد جبهه عريضه
مناهضه لايران الان لا يمكن ان تكون هذه
الجبهه فعاله وبخاصه مع وجود القوات
الامريكيه في قطر في قا في قاعده العديد
وكل هذه الخلافات بين الدول الخليجيه وهنا
طبعا الحديث عن دول الحصار البحرين
الامارات وايضا السعوديه المطلوب المطلوب
من هذه الدول ان ان ترتب الويات
الاستراتيجيه بعيده عن المماحكات وبعيد عن
ال يعني الزهو والغرور وال والايجو بمعنى
الشعور بالكبرياء بعيد عن كل هذا هناك
مصلحه حيويه للسعوديه كما تقول السعوديه
وكما تقول الامارات وكما تقول اسرائيل
وايضا كما تقول ولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بان هناك حاجه لهذه الجبهه هل يمكن لهذه
الجبهه ان تكون فعاله ماينس او ناقص قطر
والخلاف مع قطر قطر لا تستطيع ان ان ان
تقوم يعني مجالها الجوي محدود فوق فوق
الخليج فبالتالي انا بتقديري هذا هو
المدخل المدخل هو ان هناك اجماع استراتيجي
بين الدول الوازن هنا نتحدث عن السعودي
وايضا الامارات او اسبارطه الصغيره
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانه لابد من
يعني الاستثمار الاستثمار وما اسسه نوع من
التحالف مناهض لقطر فان بتقديري هذا هو
عامل الضغط لكن ايضا انا عندي شكوك كثيره
جدا بان ترامب في اخر شهرين ربما يكون
منشغل اكثر مما ينبغي في عاده الانتخاب
وبخاصه وان استطلاعات الرائي لا تظهر له
اي تقدم في الفتره الاخيره في في اهم
الولايات وحتى في البوبر فوت بمعنى ال
الصوت كل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
ان ان تمكن من احداث انفراج سيكون هذا
رصيد ايضا انتخابي لكن انا بتقديري هو
الجائزه الكبرى هي الامارات والبحرين الذي
يسوقها في اعلامه ربما الازمه الخليجيه
على اهميتها ربما تنتظر قليلا الى ان ان
تنجل الامور مع الانتخابات دكتور ماجد
سريعا ايضا موقف قطر واضح بما يتعلق
بتحالف في المنطقه ضد دوله اخرى في في هذه
المنطقه كيف ستتعامل مع طرح ما طرحوه
الضيوف الان وهو انشاء هذه الجبهه لمواجهه
ايران كيف ستتعامل معها قطر من منطلق حل
الازمه الخليجيه انا قد اختلف قليلا مع
الزملاء
حول اولويه مواجهه ايران بالنسبه لترامب
في ظل اخر شهرين من ولايته الاولى انا لا
اعتقد ان ترامب اليوم متحمس لان يكون باي
جديد فيما يتعلق بايران سوى الاستمرار في
سياسه الماكسيمم بريشر او
الضغط الاقصى على على على ايران اقتصاديا
بشكل رئيسي من الناحيه
الاخرى قطر راهنت على مساله منذ البدايه
الدول الاخرى ارادت انتصارات تكتيكيه في
مقابل ان تقدم تنازلات استراتيجيه قطر
ارادت انجازات استراتيجيه في مقابل انها
قد تخسر تكتيكيا وهذا ما تم في النهايه في
اللحظه الاولى كان هناك اتهام لقطر بانها
تدعم حماس في غزه وانها تدعم طالبان وغير
ذلك اليوم يعود وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
ليستخدم هاتين النقطتين تحديدا ليثير
الثناء على قطر نجاح قطر في الهدنه في غزه
نجاح قطر في عقد مفاوضات بين الافغان
وتحقيق السلام في افغانستان بعد 20 عاما
منيات المتحده والاستقرار في لبنان
والاستقرار في سوريا ما اريد ان اقوله هنا
هو انه بينما الطرف الثاني اراد ان يحقق
انتصارات شكليه لصالح ترامب ما حدث هو ان
الانجاز الحقيقي الذي حقق ليس المصلحه
الامريكيه فقط بل مصلحه متبادله بين
افغانستان والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
سوريا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والشعب
السوريا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لبنان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكل الاطراف
تح تحقيق مصلحتها الىى جوار المصلحه
الامريكيه بما فيها مصلحه قطر كانت تلك
قطر بينما الطرف الاخر ما زال يريد ان
يردد هذه الانتصارات الوهميه دون ان يكون
هناك اهتمام بالمصلحه العامه الشعبيه
والرسميه لنفهم اهميه قطر بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه سيد نيو باور
بالنهايه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او
اداره الرئيس ترامب تراهن على دوله محاصره
اجوائها محاصره حدودها مع جيرانها مغلقه
ما اهميه الدبلوماسيه القطريه بالنسبه
لاداره الرئيس ترامب في تحقيق سلام خاصه
وتحقيق الوعود بسحب القوات الامريكيه من
هذه
المنطقه اعتقد انه من المهم ان
نفهم انه رغم ان ترمب يود سحب قواته من
افغانستان فذلك لا يعني بالضروره انه يريد
انسحاب قواته من دول اخرى في الشرق الاوسط
اعتقد ان هذه كان امر متكرر غالبا نسمع في
الخليج بان الامريكان يريدون الانسحاب من
كل المنطقه وانا لا اعتقد ان هذا صحيح
الولايات
المتحده لديها علاقات استراتيجيه وشراكات
استراتيجيه عسكريه مع دول الخليج باقوى من
اي وقت وقد شاهدنا ان كل دول الخليج بما
ذلك عمان هي في
مقدمه الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه في طريقه
التعامل مع قضايا كثيره بالنسبه قطر
تتعامل مع غز وافغانستان بطريقه جيده
وشاهدنا ان عمان تقترب الى حد كبير ال
الاداره الامريكيه وشاهدنا ذلك بالنسبه
للبحرين وتقترب من والامارات يقتربون من
اسرائيل اذا كل هذه الامور مترابطه فيما
بينها وهذه في اول مره رغم الحصار والامور
السلبيه الحشره منطقه الخليج نجد ان
الداره الامريكيه لديها مصالح استراتيجيه
اصيله حقيقيه لتعزيز العلاقات بين ولاي
المتحده ودول الخليج وهذه تعتبر اولويه
كبرى بالنسبه لاداره ترامب ولا يمكن تحقيق
ذلك دون حل الازمه الموجوده بين دول
الخليج اذا كل الامور مترابطه فيما بينها
وكل شخص من
الرئيس الى جارد كوشنر والى وزير الخارجيه
وطبعا الوزير منوشن الذي هو صديق مقرب جدا
لقطر ايضا الكل يدفع بشهد للوي الاذرعه
لكن ب نفس الوقت يقدمون فرصه فوز لجميع
الاطراف للجميع في الخليج واعتقد هذا هو
المقاربه الامريكيه واعتقد فعلا بان نقترب
جدا الى مصالحه بين دول الخليج لان هذا
يعتبر نصر كبير في السياسه الخارجيه
لترامب وهو ما يسعى اليه اضافه ان الحصار
كان ظالما بشكل كبير ضد الشعب القطري وان
حكومه قطر قريبه جدا من الولايات المتحده
وانا نشهد ذلك في اخر جوله من الحوار
الاستراتيجي بين بينهما بان الجهد سيكون
لتعزيز العلاقات ما بين الشعبين الشعب
القطري والشعب الامريكي وبالتالي فالضغوط
هي مستمره واعتقد انه بشكل
عام العلاقات من الولايات المتحده والخليج
وبشكل مفارق لم تكن افضل ما هي عليه الان
وبالتالي لا اجد هناك اي امكانيه حقيقيه
بان امريكا ستنسحب من طقه الخليج دكتور
حسن ما المكانه
التي تضعها قطر لنفسها لاقا وعلى ضوء هذه
الاشاده الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بملف
المصالحه الافغانيه الافغانيه وا
الاستقرار او الحفاظ على الاستقرار
ومساهمه في الاستقرار في المنطقه
بتقديرك بتقدير التفسير القطري لكل ما تق
ما تقول الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من
تصريحات على لسان كل المسؤولين بانها هي
على حق فيما يتعلق بكثير من المواقف اولا
توظف قوتها الناعمه من اجل الاستقرار في
حين غيرها يوظف قوته الخشنه من اجل زعزعه
الاستقرار وهذا يعني في كل ملفات
الاقليميه واضح تماما يعني لا يحتاج الى
اثباتات فبالتالي انا اعتقد ان قطر تشعر
بثقه كبيره جدا بعد ان تمكنت من تعزيز
قوتها الاقليميه والدوليه فقوه قطر ليست
فقط قوه ذاتيه وانما ايضا قوتها
بتحالفاتها فعندما تاتي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتماس هذا الحوار الاستراتيجي و
وتشيد بالسياسه القطريه الخارجيه في كل
الملفات العالقه وال والحساسه فيما يتعلق
بغزه فيما يتعلق بافغانستان وحتى لبنان
وسوريا هذا يعني ان قطر ستستمر بنفس
السياسه ان ما تقوم به قطر هو مثار اعجاب
المجتمع الدولي بالتالي عندما ياتي وزير
خارجيه اكبر دوله في العالم اقوى دوله في
العالم يشيد بقطر انا اعتقد ان الساسه في
قطر او القياده القطريه ستستمر في نفس
النهج على اعتبار ان كل ما قامت به هو
صحيح بانها مظلومه في الحصار وان على
الطرف الاخر ان يلتقي معها في منتصف
الطريق على الطاوله الحوار وليس على طريقه
الاملاءات وايضا التركيع ومحاوله اخضاع
السياسه الخارجيه القطريه وفقا لاولويات
في الاقليم هذا الكلام لن يمر ولن تقبل
فيه القياده القطريه وبخاصه بعد ثلاث
سنوات من الحصار وبعد ان اشاد المجتمع
الدولي في قوتها وصمودها وايضا ح حسن
تدبيرها في السياسه الخارجيه دكتور ماجد
الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن اشار الى ان قطر
قوت علاقاتها بالاسره الدوليه وليس فقط
بامريكا بشكل غير مسبوق ما
مستقبل هذه العلاقات خاصه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انطلاقا من الدور الذي
تلعبه الان قطر في المنطقه يعني اريد قطر
من خلال الحصار ان تنكمش في علاقاتها
الدوليه ما نراه اليوم هو ان ذات الملفات
التي استخدمت ضد قطر وتشويه سمعه قطر هي
الملفات التي تنجح فيها قطر اليوم وتحقق
نجاحات دوليه اليوم قطر هي شريك يعني
للعالم شريك دولي وشريك ذو مصداقيه عاليه
في ملفات كما قال الزميل حسن ملفات حساسه
وملفات عالقه وملفات لم يستطع احد حقيقه
تحرير تقدم فيها كبير خلال السنوات
الاخيره قطر في المرحله القادمه مع
الولايات المتحده وغيرها هي تنطلق من
دائره المصالح المشتركه باعتبارها لاعب
بناء دولي ليس تابعا لاحد لا يقدم تنازلات
لمجرد التنازلات ولا يقدم سلام لمجرد
السلام لاعب دولي يحقق المصلحه لجميع
الاطراف من خلال توافقات دوليه حقيقيه
وقدرات قوه ناعمه يعني مستمده من تجارب
حقيقيه لدى قطر نحن راينا كيف ان قطر
تجاوزت هذا الحصار من تحويلها الى حاله
الانكماش الذي اريد لها ان تكون فيه الى
ان تكون قطر هي رقم الاصعب اليوم وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي يقول عبر شا العالم
اجمع بانان الولايات المتحده تقر بان قطر
نجحت في مواجهه حصارها وتحولت الى لاعب
نحن نعتقد انه اداه مهمه جدا لتحقيق
الاستقرار الدولي شكرا لكم جميعا الدكتور
ماجد الانصاري هنا في الاستوديو سيجورد
نيو باور في واشنطن والدكتور حسن البراري
في
عمان